So, The New York Times has just published
its list of must-see places to go in 2019
and nestled quietly in the top 25 destinations
is none other than the Falkland Islands.
We’re not talking tropical island paradise
here, we’re talking about a remote, archipelago
in the South Atlantic, more than 700 islands
exposed to the harsh elements, with a tiny
population of just over 3,000.
A territory as empty as it is inhospitable.
Nevertheless, this windblown backwater was
the cause of intense political tension in
the second half of the twentieth century,
culminating in a war between the United Kingdom
and Argentina.
It’s important to understand here that for
Argentinians, the Falklands issue is a national
issue.
Argentinian children learn very, very early
that the Falklands are a part of Argentina..
For them, the British “occupation” of
the islands was nothing more than imperial
plunder.
“In peace with nobility and in peace with
honour.
But we will also chase anyone who dares touch
a square metre of Argentine territory”
So given its controversial history, the New
York Times listsparked a few questions:.
Do the Falkland Islands belong to Argentina?
And why are they so important to mainland
Argentinianss?
After all, Argentina is a huge country, the
eighth largest country in the world.
So why all the fuss about this remote, inhospitable
and largely uninhabited archipelago?
Well, this video aims to answer these questions..
First things first, Let’s find out how it
all began…
THE ORIGIN OF AN ENDLESS DISPUTE
The beginning of the nineteenth century.
The Spanish colonies in America begin to protest
against Spanish rule.
The recent United States Declaration of Independence
and the French Revolution have ignited a desire
for autonomy and freedom that cannot be suppressed.
In 1808, the Napoleonic invasion of Spain
led to the dismantling of Madrid’s power
and that kicked off a race towards independence
that more or less resulted in Latin America
as we know it today.
So it was that on May 25th, 1810, just two
years after the French occupation of Spain,
the municipal council of the City of Buenos
Aires decided to replace the Viceroy of the
Río de la Plata with the First Government
Junta.
Argentinians today think of this as their
first patriotic government.
Argentina was on its own road to revolution
but it wouldn’t be free of Spain until six
years later.
On July 9th, 1816 came the proclamation of
independence of the United Provinces of the
Rio de la Plata.
And this is where the first confusion arises:
You see, many people think that the Viceroyalty
of the Rio de la Plata, created in 1776 by
King Carlos III of Spain, was synonymous with
what we know of today as Argentina... but
it wasn’t the case.
Let me explain.
While it’s true that the Viceroyalty of
the Río de la Plata included modern-day Argentina,
it also included Uruguay, Bolivia and Paraguay.
Some of you must be thinking, “Hang on Simon,
where do the Falklands fit in with all of
this?”
Well the fact is that Uruguay, Paraguay and
Bolivia, along with the Falkland Islands,
were all part of the Viceroyalty of the Rio
de la Plata…
The thing is, I don’t think that you’ll
find many Argentinians claiming sovereignty
over Paraguay, Bolivia or Uruguay these days.
And of course if they did, everyone would
think they were crazy.
So why the Falklands?
The fact that the Falklands were part of this
mammoth Viceroyalty which belonged to the
Spanish crown is not surprising.
What is surprising is Argentina’s claim
on the Falklands, especially given that, until
this territory was consolidated as a British
sovereignty, it was passed back and forth
between European powers numerous times.
(FROM HAND TO HAND, FROM PLAY TO PLAY)
The history of the Falkland Islands is actually
much simpler and shorter than some may think.
You see, until the mid 1700s the FalklandIslands
weren’t even inhabited on a permanent basis.
And the first people to live there permanently
were not the British or the Spanish, but the
French.
Yes, you heard that correctly, the French.
But, that’s only the start.
Between 1764 and 1833, the islands passed
from one nation to another:
first from France to Spain, then to England,
then backto Spain and finally, since 1833,
the Falkland have been under British sovereignty.
So let’s do some quick addition.
Since they began to be permanently occupied,
the Falklands have been under Spanish sovereignty
for just over 40 years and under British sovereignty
for more than 180 years.
So why does Argentina stake its claim so vigorously?
Well it all goes back to the time between
the May Revolution and the subsequent declaration
of independence of the United Provinces of
the Rio de la Plata.
At that time, the local authorities began
sending expeditions to the Falkland islands,
which they considered their own.
And this is precisely where the controversy
arose.
Because while the Argentinian version insists
that the English snatched part of their territory
in 1833, the truth is that, at that time Argentina
was still a work in progress and its borders
were far from defined.
Not convinced?
Check this out:
Just five years before the British returned
to the Falklands in 1833, Argentina lost Uruguay;
What’s more, it took until 1862, that’s
almost three decades later, for Argentina
to have a national president.
In other words, in 1833 when the English regained
control over the Falklands, Argentina’s
borders were yet to be decided, there was
no Argentinian national government, and so
of course they didn’t have anything like
a national army.
In fact, it may seem hard to believe, but
between the years 1852 and 1860, the state
of Buenos Aires wasn’t even part of the
Argentine Confederation.
But in the grand scheme of things, this isn’t
so extraordinary.
Stories rely on continuous changes in the
rules of the game.
Viewed through a historical prism, sovereignties
come and go all the time.
Now, it’s clear that history can be framed
and interpreted in many different ways.
And that may explain why many Argentinians
insist that when the English reasserted control
over the Falklands in 1833, the islands were
already a part of Argentina as we know it
today and therefore, part of the Argentinian
homeland.
But, let's see,190 years later and can you
guesshow many people of Argentinian origin
live in the Falkland Islands today?
Only 18.
In fact, there are almost ten times as many
inhabitants from Chile as there are from Argentina.
Nevertheless, not so long ago, the contested
sovereignty was grounds for war.
(AN UNEXPECTED WAR)
Ever since the British regained control of
the Falkland Islands, Argentina has wanted
them back.
It’s been like a national obsession through
the generations.
In 1888 they began publishing maps that included
these previously disregarded islands within
Argentina’s borders.
Now let’s just be clear that, apart from
the map redesign, there were no great claims
on the Falklands from either side until the
Second World War.
Up until then, Argentina and England were
two friendly allies.
In fact, the Latin American country that received
the most direct and indirect investments from
England was Argentina.
But... after the Second World War...
Everything changed.
For one thing, commercial relations between
the countries were no longer as significant.
Secondly, the election of General Perón as
Argentina’s president gave weight to his
nationalist and anti-imperialist discourse.
And thirdly, the newly created United Nations
was focused on the process of decolonization.
In fact, UN resolution 2065 invited Argentina
and the UK to clear up the matter of the Falklands’
sovereignty in 1965.
But within just two years of this resolution,
the situation had taken a 180-degree turn.
In 1967 London told the Argentinian government
that it was willing to cede sovereignty over
the Falklands, but on one condition: they
had to respect the wishes of the kelpers,
or Falkland Island inhabitants.
The only problem was that the kelpers opposed
any sovereignty transfer point blank.
In fact, they actively mobilized against the
possibility by creating what became known
as the “Falklands Lobby”.
And it seems that at the time, the British
government was willing to deliver, or at least
share, sovereignty over the Falklands in exchange
for commercial agreements.
Let me stress here that it was the islands’
inhabitants themselves who prevented this:
( “In the mid-1960s pragmatism would have
probably led the British government to transfer
the sovereignty of the Falklands had not the
Falklands Lobby arisen to counter the pressure
of Argentine demands”.
Clive Ellerby, an English researcher, author
of the work “Role of the Falklands Lobby”.
And that is how things stood on April 2nd,
1982.
(“May the world know, and America, of a
people with a will, of the Argentine people:
if they want to come, let them, we’ll fight
them.”)
On that day, a grim military government led
by General Leopoldo Galtieri held power in
Argentina.
It was a discredited and repressive regime,
without the people’s support and responsible
for one of the darkest periods in Argentina’s
modern history.
Many citizens were branded political prisoners,
thousands more simply disappeared, and a huge
economic crisis was crippling the economy.
On that day, Galtieri’s government made
a fateful decision:
Gain the people’s support by feeding their
patriotic fervour.
The Argentinian government decided to invade
and occupy the Falkland Islands.
The Argentinian authorities expected this
move to spur a diplomatic agreement to be
reached rapidly with the UK.
However, they underestimated this woman's
determination:
Margaret Thatcher, the Prime Minister of the
United Kingdom, was willing to fight a war
thousands of kilometres away.
The outcome was disastrous.
The British army’s technological and military
superiority, coupled with the Argentinian
government’s lack of planning - they carried
out the invasion with many young, poorly equipped
and poorly trained soldiers - allowed the
United Kingdom to recover the islands in a
little over two months.
So once again, a tyrannical government’s
political decision ended with a war as unnecessary
as it was useless, costing the lives of hundreds
of people.
Look, we know how sensitive these types of
border issues can be.
And with this video we want to put some facts
on the table and maybe give you a new perspective:
Because throughout history, territories have
passed from one power to another.
For more than 300 years what is now Argentina
was under Spanish rule, for more than 180
years the Falklands have been British.
But what does it matter who was or wasn’t
right 200 years ago?
Isn’t it more important to think about where
we are today and to build a more harmonious
future?
Just a reflection from VisualPolitik.
Now, here are some more questions; Why is
there so much interest in the Falklands?
What’s special about these islands?
These are topics we’re going to address
in an upcoming video here on VisualPolitik.
But before we go, we’d really like to hear
your thoughts: What do you think should happen
with the Falklands?
Leave your answers in the comments as well
as in the survey.
So I really hope you enjoyed this video, please
hit like if you did, and don’t forget to
subscribe for brand new videos.
Don’t forget to check out our friends at
the Reconsider Media Podcast - they provided
the vocals in this episode that were not mine.
Also, this channel is possible because of
Patreon, and our patrons on that platform.
Please consider joining them and supporting
our mission of providing independent political
coverage.
And as always, I’ll see you in the next
video.